the over-promised of what success looks
like is what's causing people to lose it
leads to a bigger conversation of
self-awareness I think the biggest
mistake most of us make is we hope who
we are
instead of auditing who we are okay
everybody wants to be somebody like look
I really want to be the [ __ ]
quarterback of the New York Jets but
truth is like I don't have it like that
like I don't have those pieces and I
think everybody believes that they can
be an entrepreneur or business person
yeah is there's a ton of kids right now
who could be the number two or the
number three or number four the number
six guy at Facebook made a fuckload of
money yeah and right now that guy and
that gal because of the all the
entrepreneurship talk is trying to start
a company there are a lot of people
especially when they were built to be
good students and be good number fours
and 7s that when they go to be a 1 and
after a life full of winning because
they understood that system they go into
the actual marketplace no more rich
friends and families and connections in
private school and good universities
nobody gives a [ __ ] who your dad is it's
almost like when rap got big like
everybody just decided I'm gonna be a
rapper
like you can't just decide you're gonna
be an entrepreneur and I think a lot of
people have been extending their college
lives and disguising it as
entrepreneurship I work [ __ ] hard I
came here with zero
I didn't have a single [ __ ] vacation
day or weekend since I was in the
seventh grade
I'm not pumped about losing my money you
have a lot of people that are built DNA
wise and skill wise and have studied em
every school and have been formed and
obtained to be unbelievable consultants
at Bain a McKinsey other places have a
great career and then get involved in
entrepreneurial ventures where they can
leverage the monies they made and invest
and things of that nature who are
starting consumer apps out the gate and
have no [ __ ] clue how to be a true
bred entrepreneur because they don't the
stomach to deal when the market says go
[ __ ] yourself I think that we've just
went through the golden era of people
saying they were entrepreneurs but what
they were was they were operators that
were building machines making companies
that were built for financial arbitrage
people been building startups that are
predicated on raising the next round
you've been building your company for
user growth to raise your next round
you're not building we are lacking self
awareness in this space in a very
substantial way and there's a lot of
people that are about to be met with a
lot of disappointment and are struggling
and one thing we're not talking about is
the level of success everybody thinks
they have to build [ __ ] uber
everybody thinks they have to make
millions of dollars
it's unbelievable what we've done and I
absolutely want to make sure that we're
starting to have real conversations
making $100,000 a year that's massively
successful we need to recalibrate what
success looks like in our space because
we're forcing through the branding of
what we're doing very impractical very
high-risk very low return results for so
many because everybody's shooting for 10
billion and if we keep telling everybody
to do it and if we don't start talking
about that the entry level to be in the
top 1% earners in America is only
$400,000 a year and then use the word
only because nobody here is even in the
mindset of million-dollar or bust right
we need to start having proper
conversations